avoir 20 ans en 2020 la suite de nos
portraits
aujourd'hui rencontre avec kevin après
avoir vécu dans la rue ce jeune
dijonnais a réussi à trouver un travail
et un logement
bamba guèye et amélie d'où elles ont
rencontré
ces lieux c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir 20
en 2009 c'est tout
[Musique]
appliquez mené les dragées 20 ans je
suis livreur à moi j'étais au chômage
[Musique]
dans ma jeunesse j'étais placé dans un
foyer
après franchement déçu mes parents j'ai
sué un peu mauvais chemin des
répétitions bêtise convocation de
compassion marware métier c'était de
voler un scooter à devant le
commissariat conditions permis délit
twitch ils ont presque voulu envoyer en
prison ça c'est derrière moi les jeux
j'arrête effet débuté comme poste
comment les tête-à-tête avec mon père
m'avait dit fan2 fr bourthois je
l'écouté je l'atteins se réfléchir je
suis parti bien j'avais pas trop où
aller
du coup j'ai fait un peu de rues projet
local syndical
franchement il faut laisser des caresses
et l'expérience durera dur à gérer parce
que là bas c'est pas si facile
du coup je suis parti
je trouve l appartement avec un pote à
moi beaucoup dé devenir
il faisait un peu les bourses pour
qu'ils pouvaient sinon j'avais un peu au
pop côté est vraiment rien au peuple
ma mère avec qui j'avais encore de
contact
à noter un peu de pain de seigle de
courtes histoires l'aspect
je sais que c'est dur du monde une
beauté
autour d'un bâton
vous souhaitez le travail déjà c'est un
truc qui nous les jeunes on a du mal à
trouver parce que les patrons ne
prennent pas vraiment au sérieux du coup
ils veulent pas trop mais c'est notre
chance mondiale j'ai trouvé en justement
aux commandes d'une pizza normal si ça
s'appelle une personne ils m'ont dit si
j'ai postulé et une semaine après et
m'ont dit oui
depuis j'ai mon travail ça va je me sens
mieux c'est comment elle et j'ai de
l'avant qui on est tombés tous les mois
une scie ratio comment va aujourd'hui ça
va attendu ce cas des 2 c ça peut être
très long et s'il me défaire par ce même
pas vu du soutien affluent je verrai
mais d'abord même si nous en sortir et
voir si c'est trop compliqué là
peut-être que j'irais les voir lors des
montées de tête ça va j'ai fait un petit
à petit chaque soir un peu pour voir tu
vois on s'accrochait faut aller chercher
ces villes se retrouvent à la rue comme
pas mal de jeunes sur des ruptures
familiales et qui vise quelqu'un de très
autonome de quelqu'un de très dynamique
très respectueux enfin c'est très
agréable de bosser avec lui il est
réactif il est dans les changes juste de
la stabilité je sais que lens moment il
travaille
j'espère que ça va se transformer en cdi
et qui fut stabiliser la suite
2 je mettais à ce qu'est la boxe
anglaise pas mal plus hachée que c'est
un peu un rêve mais on verra ça m'a
calais dans l'événement
c'est un mélange de tout sport de combat
est pour sa part quelques vis de nous 18
quand je suis pas le genre de personne
qui va se projeter loin loin loin
donc maintenant je pense que de ce fait
j'ai pas bidon